[Applause]
some staffers at the Kelly Clarkson show
claim it's a toxic work environment it's
a dream I didn't know I had and I mean
it turned out to be like such a dream
job like I love it I love my team that
I'm working with here one current and 10
former employees of the show opened up
to Rolling Stone about the alleged
conditions claiming they were overworked
underpaid and their time at the show was
traumatizing to their mental health one
former employee says NBC the network
that airs the daytime talk show is
protecting the show because it's their
new money maker but Kelly has no clue
how unhappy her staff is another former
staffer defends the daytime host Kelly
is fantastic she is a person who never
treats anyone with anything but dignity
I would be shocked if she knew the point
is the people and that's what we do on
the show as well it's about people
whether they're celebrities or
non-celebrity the staffers who requested
to remain anonymous claim everything
from having to take on side hustles to
pay their bills to being yelled and
cursed at by high-level producers
several of the employees also claim they
took their concerns to HR but say
nothing changed and nbcu spokesperson
tells ET they are committed to a safe
and respectful work environment and take
workplace complaints very seriously
adding that to insinuate otherwise is
untrue when issues are reported they are
promptly reviewed investigated and acted
upon as appropriate the spokesperson
adds that the Kelly Clarkson show
strives to build a safe respectful and
Equitable workplace that nurtures a
culture of inclusivity and creativity
because I've been working on listening
and it's not that I don't
really pausing the Rolling Stone article
comes from the same journalist who
reported in 2021 claims that the work
environment at the Ellen DeGeneres show
was toxic allegations that prompted the
show to launch an internal investigation
which led to the firing of three
executive producers it was devastating
it was it because it started with me it
started with a tax on me and attacking
everything that I stand for and believe
in and Built My Career around like I
just I am a kind person I am a person
who likes to make people happy and after
all that Ellen announced that season 19
would be her last how are you going to
know when it's the right time to walk
away from daytime I hope I know when
when people kind of are tired of me I
think I'll sense that I'll walk away
really when I when I stop having fun as
for the Kelly Clarkson show it's been a
hit ever since its debut in 2019.
[Music]
just leave me
you know I was terrified at first and
the pilot I was like okay I got better
throughout it and then like we just
taped like our first two shows and I was
really proud of myself and it actually
has been really cool and earlier this
week the show which is currently in its
fourth season announced they are
relocating from Los Angeles to New York
City with a source telling E.T Kelly's
ready for the move and excited for a new
change
[Music]
foreign